foreign
's YouTube channel today we have an
exciting topic that often Sparks debates
in the tech World Cloud architect versus
the cloud engineer anyone who wants to
become a professional in cloud computing
often gets confused between these two
highly sought after rules so let's just
see the differences between both of them
and this video will help you choose the
right cloud computing career we'll dive
deep into the roles responsibilities and
skills that set these two rules apart
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you deal
also hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply load
whether you are a fresher or an I.T
expert with some experience you can
improve your skills in cloud computing
by getting the proper training and
certifications on that note we present
the Caltech cloud computing bootcamp by
simply loan this in-depth cloud
computing online bootcamp course lets
you master fundamental architectural
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a cloud expert you can become
a complete Cloud architect in just six
months whether you are a fresher looking
to make a career in cloud computing or
any working professional looking for a
change in your career you can offer this
cloud computing bootcamp not just that
but there are many other attractive
features of this boot camp like 40 plus
Hands-On projects and integrated Labs
will help you understand the concepts
much better Capstone projects in four
different domains make sure that you
have mastered this technology
a bootcamp certificate from Caltech ctme
is worth mentioning in your CV live
virtual classes led by industry exports
Hands-On projects and integrated labs
simply learns career service is here to
help you get noticed by the top hiring
companies
several other features are also there in
this boot camp in simple terms Caltech
cloud computing bootcamp helps you
become an expert in designing planning
and scaling cloud implementations
from cloud provider selection
application migration and performance
testing to database management
multi-cloud deployment and storage
Services we have covered every skill in
this program to help you become a
successful Cloud architect
for admissions to this cloud computing
bootcamp candidates with OnePlus years
of experience are preferred so are you
ready to work with companies like
Microsoft Google Oracle LinkedIn and
Accenture don't wait until it's too late
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below and we are here to
guide support and Empower you with the
skills to keep you ahead in the race
so without any further delay let's start
this video with who is a cloud architect
a cloud architect is a professional
specializing in designing and overseeing
the architecture of cloud computing
solutions for organizations they are
responsible for creating the blueprint
and strategic plan for an organization's
Cloud infrastructure and ensuring that
it aligns with the businesses goals and
requirements they need a deep
understanding of cloud Technologies
architecture security and excellent
communication skills to work effectively
with different teams and stakeholders
so let's dive into their rules and
responsibilities
Cloud Architects are responsible for
Designing Cloud Solutions Cloud
Architects are responsible for creating
the architectural blueprints for cloud
infrastructures and services their
Design Systems that leverage the
capabilities of cloud platforms like
Amazon web services Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform or others to meet
specific business requirements
strategic planning they work closely
with stakeholders including Business
Leaders and it teams to understand the
organization's goals and translate them
into Cloud strategies these strategies
often involve migration from on-premises
systems to the cloud or optimizing
existing Cloud environments
selecting cloud services
Cloud Architects choose the right
combination of cloud services and
Technologies to create efficient
scalable and cost effective Solutions
this involves selecting Computer
Resources storage options databases
networking configurations and many more
security and compliance ensuring the
security and compliance of cloud system
is a crucial aspect of their rule they
Implement security best practices
encryptions and access controls and
regularly monitor for vulnerabilities
and compliance with industry regulations
cost optimization Cloud Architects are
responsible for managing Cloud costs
they Implement cost saving measures such
as right sizing resources optimizing
data storage and using reserved
instances to ensure that the
organizations get the most value from
its Cloud Investments
team collaboration collaboration is the
key and Cloud Architects often work
closely with Cloud Engineers devops
teams and other ID professionals to
implement and maintain Cloud Solutions
staying updated Cloud technology evolves
rapidly so Cloud Architects must stay up
to date with the latest Cloud Trends
services and best practices to ensure
their designs remain relevant and
efficient
documentation they create comprehensive
documentation for cloud architectures
configurations and strategies this
documentation is crucial for maintaining
and troubleshooting Cloud systems now
Cloud Architects need a deep
understanding of certain skills which
include Cloud platform expertise
Proficiency in one or more major Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure or Google Cloud platform
or others in-app knowledge of the cloud
service and offerings provided by The
Chosen cloud provider Cloud architecture
and design the ability to design Cloud
architectures that align with the
organization's business goals and
Technical requirements understanding of
architectural patterns and best
practices for scalability availability
and reliability
security and compliance strong knowledge
of cloud security best practices
including identity and access management
encryptions network security and
compliance standards experience in
implementing security controls to
protect Cloud resources networking
Proficiency in designing and configuring
Cloud Network architectures including
virtual networks subnets and routing
knowledge of hybrid Cloud networking and
connecting on-premises infrastructure to
the cloud
the fifth is cloud service and
Technologies familiarity with many cloud
services including Computing storage
databases containers serverless and more
experience in selecting the right cloud
services for specific use cases and the
last one is infrastructure as code
Proficiency in infrastructure as code
tools like terraform AWS cloud formation
or Azure resource manager to automate
infrastructure provisioning and
management if you want to build a
rewarding career with Cloud architect
certifications then simply learns Cloud
architect certification course will help
you build your AWS Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform expertise from the
ground up you learn to master the
architectural principles and services of
the top Cloud platforms design and
deploy highly scalable fault tolerant
applications and develop skills to
transform yourself into an AWS or Azure
Cloud the cloud architect certification
program is designed to make you an
expert in Cloud applications and
architectures it will enable you to
master the core skill sets required for
Designing and deploying dynamically
scalable highly available fault tolerant
and reliable applications on three of
the top Cloud platform providers Amazon
web services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform this program will give
you an in-depth understanding of cloud
services such as AWS cloud formation
Azure resource manager ec2 S3 Route 53
VPC Azure app services gcp and many more
you will acquire the Knowledge and
Skills for passing Cloud architect
certifications such as AWS architect and
Azure architect on top of that this
program includes an Azure exam voucher
that can be available to appear for any
one course
for admission to This Cloud architect
Masters program candidates with OnePlus
year of work experience are preferred so
what are you waiting for check out the
link mentioned in the description box
below for more details
so let's move on to Cloud engineers
Cloud engineer is a professional
responsible for Designing implementing
and managing clouds Computing Solutions
and infrastructures for organizations
they work with Cloud Technologies and
platform to enable businesses to
leverage the benefit of cloud computing
such as scalability flexibility cost
efficiency and accessibility to
resources and services
so let's dive into the rules and
responsibilities of a cloud engineer the
first is cloud architecture Cloud
Engineers design the architecture of
cloud-based systems deciding how
resources and services will be organized
and integrated within a cloud
environment
they choose the appropriate cloud
service providers like Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure or Google cloud
and design solutions that align within
organization's goals and requirements
infrastructure as code they often use
infrastructure as code tools and
practices to automate the provisioning
configuration and management of cloud
resources this approach ensures
consistency repeatability and Version
Control of infrastructure components
Cloud migration Cloud Engineers
assistant migrating existing on-premises
applications and workloads to the cloud
this involves assessing current systems
planning the migration strategy and
executing the migration process to
ensure minimal disruption security and
compliance ensuring the security and
compliance of a cloud environment is a
Paramount concern for cloud and genius
they Implement security measures
configure access controls and monitor
for potential security threats and
vulnerabilities
performance optimization Cloud Engineers
continuously Monitor and optimize Cloud
resources to maintain Optimal
Performance while controlling costs this
includes adjusting resource allocations
optimizing database configurations and
implementing caching strategies
Automation and devops they collaborate
with devops teams to automate deployment
processes integrate continuous
integration and continuous delivery
pipelines and streamline the software
development life cycle in the cloud
troubleshooting and support Cloud
Engineers are responsible for diagnosing
and resolving issues in the cloud
environment such as network problems
service disruptions or performance
bottlenecks
so Cloud Engineers also need a deep
understanding of certain skills which
include Cloud platform knowledge
familiarity with one or more major Cloud
platforms such as AWS Azure gcp or
others is crucial each platform has its
own set of services tools and features
so understanding how to use them is
essential for a cloud engine
Cloud architecture understanding Cloud
architecture principles including how to
design scalable resilient and cost
effective Solutions is fundamental you
should be able to create architectural
diagrams and decide which cloud services
to use for different scenarios
networking a solid understanding of
networking Concepts including virtual
networks subnets security groups load
balancing and DNS is crucial for
configuring and securing Cloud
environments security
Cloud security is a top priority a cloud
engineer should be well versed with
identity and access management
encryption firewall configurations and
security best practices to protect Cloud
resources and data operating systems
Proficiency in various operating systems
like Linux and windows is important
because Cloud instances often run these
operating systems knowing how to manage
and troubleshoot them in a cloud
environment is valuable scripting and
coding skills and scripting languages
like python bash or Powershell are
beneficial for automating tasks and
writing custom scripts to interact with
Cloud API so there you have it the
skills required for a cloud engineer so
let's quickly go through the key
differences between these two rules
the first is rules
Cloud Architects primarily focus on
designing the overall Cloud
infrastructure and developing long-term
Cloud strategies Cloud Engineers on the
other hand are professionals responsible
for implementing managing and
maintaining Cloud environments
responsibilities responsibilities of a
cloud architect include solution design
Cloud strategy security and compliance
and cost optimization Cloud Engineers on
the other hand are responsible for
infrastructure deployment automation
troubleshooting scaling and monitoring
skills a cloud architect should possess
skills like Cloud expertise architecture
design security knowledge communication
and business acumen a cloud engineer on
the other hand should possess skills
like Cloud platforms scripting devops
tools networking and problem solving
last but not the least the salaries
according to class 2 the average salary
of a cloud architect in India is around
22 lakhs per annum and the same Cloud
architect working in the United States
earns around 218 000 annually with
additional cash benefits on the other
hand the average salary of a cloud
engineer in India is around 7.5 lakh
rupees per annum and the same Cloud
engineer working in the United States
earns around 141
000 annually with additional cash
benefits so there you have it choosing
between a career as a cloud architect or
a cloud engineer is a decision that
ultimately depends on your interests and
skill sets both professions offer a
promising future with a strong job
outlook and high salary potential it's
important to note that advanced
educations such as a master's degree can
provide a Competitive Edge and increase
your marketability in this field
so let's take a minute to hear it out
from our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers
finishing the course led to personal
recognition and opened the door for even
more artificial intelligence projects
and it came with a significant pay raise
my hand hi I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old
and last year's compiled skill was
simple as post-granting program in cyber
security I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course we
decided to make a course in devops from
Simply learning the course briefly very
beneficial for both our careers yeah I
got a promotion after the course and I
go to hire with a new company at first I
would like to learn from video and then
apply for your job
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn present at
the perfect route I just simply learn
because of its tremendously High waiting
to be rated as one of the best Education
portal online worldwide is truly
promising I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other possible outcomes
so with that we have come to the end of
this video on cloud architect versus
Cloud engineer I hope you found this
video interesting and helpful if you
have any doubts then you can drop them
in the comment section below and a team
of experts will definitely answer them
for you so thank you so much for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you